everybody has that one friend you know
the single-minded one the one who no
matter what the question is always finds
a way to make the answer whatever it is
she single-minded about I'm that friend
and the things that I'm single-minded
about is racism if someone were to ask
me so Janet got any plans for the 4th of
July I'm subject to answer yeah I'm
gonna binge-watch roots or if they said
Janet got a joke for you
why'd the chicken cross the road was it
a black chicken probably gentrification
[Music]
but for me single-mindedness is not just
caring about something it's caring about
something enough to do something about
it it's not just thinking it's doing
it's not just praying it is moving your
feet
and the reason I'm single minded about
racism is because I know single
mindedness can destroy it I learned that
many many years ago back in 1984 I was a
junior at Davidson College through
Davidson north carolina now Davidson is
a little bitty town southern town split
by railroad tracks white Davidson on one
side black Davidson on the other side
and as black students living on the
white side of the tracks we got used to
being stopped in downtown and asked for
ID until the police memorized our faces
but fortunately that didn't take too
long because of 1,200 students only 52
of us were black there was one black
professor one black assistant dean
things were a lot better on campus well
I wasn't okay with this and so I started
writing things and then I started
yelling things and after about three
years of that I got tired so I decided
to write one more thing and I wrote
something called project 87 project 87
was really just a challenge to Davidson
in three years by 1987 in row 100 black
students hired 10 black professors
create five black Studies classes and
hire one black Dean didn't seem
particularly revolutionary but what was
different about it was we also
challenged Davidson to say that if you
don't do this we will question your
commitment to diversity it was a real
problem we put some real numbers to it
we gave him some real consequences well
campus would absolutely nuts but
fortunately in the middle of this
Davidson got a new president and that
president was single-minded about racism
too and so he created a task force to
address the issues in project 87 and
several months after that we produced a
77 page report that report was the
foundation for all the change they came
after it now I wasn't there to see that
change because actually in 1985 I
graduated you are looking at the three
happiest people on the planet that day
because I am leaving however the change
did happen and today there are a hundred
eighty-five black students there are
sixteen black or multiracial professors
there are four black Dean's and there's
an entire degree granting Africana
Studies department
project 87 changed Davidson but it also
changed me because what it taught me was
there's a lot of power in single
mindedness well today I'm an executive
speechwriter for one of the biggest
companies in the world it's a profession
that is 92% white and predominantly male
which makes me a little bit of a unicorn
but I was single mind at unicorn so the
thing about speech writing is it's very
personal so I spend a lot of time in
deep conversation with the CEO and
senior executives and a lot of times
those conversations turn to diversity
and inclusion which of course I'm always
happy to talk about but after quite a
few of these conversations I've come to
a conclusion I believe that business is
in a position to do something that no
other entity can do business can
dismantle racism now colleges can't do
it daren't with 5,000 of them in the
United States and only 20 million
students enrolled church can't do it
either
only 35 percent of us go on a regular
basis and when we do 11 o'clock Sunday
morning is the most segregated hour in
America but business there are a hundred
and sixty-two million people in the US
workforce alone people of all races
United in the spirit of wanting a
paycheck and having to show up to get it
now I'm aware that diversity is bigger
than race and racism is bigger than
America but racial discrimination is the
most prominent form and Lord knows
America is the absolute best at it so
what if though what if we worked in
divert diverse and inclusive
environments then we had something to do
something with and since we spend one
third of our lives at work what if we
did that with people who didn't look
like us I think the world would be a
totally different place outside of work
that can happen if business gets
single-minded about
racism but now the question is how is
that supposed to happen well I think
there are three things that business can
borrow from project 87 real problems
real numbers real consequences like it
or not
diversity is not really a problem for
business yet I mean it's a nice thing to
have it's the right thing to do but for
decades we've been trying to make the
case that diversity fuels innovation and
customer insight I mean at this point
it's kind of a no-brainer a little bit
like hearing a smoke alarm going off and
standing there with your hand on the hot
door waiting for some data to tell you
that your house is on fire because the
data is already there ethnically diverse
companies perform 33 percent better than
the norm Forbes is best workplaces for
diversity enjoy 24% higher revenue
growth and yet here we are in 2018 and
there are only three black CEOs in the
fortune 500 and if your name is Molly or
Connor you got a 14% better chance of
getting the car back on your resume than
if your name is shanece or DeSean and
all of this despite the fact that by
2045 America is projected to be a
minority majority country here's the
thing the business case for diversity as
it stands today doesn't really speak to
any problem and the only way business is
going to get single-minded about racial
diversity is if it has a problem that is
urgent and relative to somebody other
than people of color I got one how about
employees and customers because no
matter what business you're in you're
gonna need those right well let's talk
about some real numbers if you have
employees and customers wouldn't it make
sense if they looked a little bit like
the people that work for you so if
that's the case maybe your employee base
should be 13 percent black and 18
percent Hispanic because that's what the
population looks like maybe
that's what your customer base looks
like but let's be clear diversity and
inclusion are not the same things
diversity is a numbers game inclusion is
about impact companies can mandate
diversity but they have to cultivate
inclusion and if inclusion is what
you're after
you got to calculate some slightly
different numbers how about 30% because
that's the point that research shows at
which the voices of minorities actually
begin to be heard if you want a real
problem you've got any real numbers to
fix it and if you're not willing to set
real numbers then maybe you're not real
serious about diversity inclusion that
brings me to my third point real
consequences think about this when
salespeople
forget and forget what they're doing and
don't come up with the numbers what do
we do we give them a little time maybe
we give them some training but then if
they don't hit those numbers eventually
we fire them however when you start
talking about diversity and inclusion we
use terms like accountability and maybe
we scold and maybe we hold back an
incentive or two but you know what the
best incentive is a job and you know it
the best disincentive is losing it so if
companies really want accountability
they should assume that that is a given
consequences are what happened when you
don't do what you're accountable for
imagine this imagine a place where
people of all colors and all races are
on and climbing every rung of the
corporate ladder where those people feel
safe indeed expected to bring their
unassimilated authentic selves to work
every day because the difference that
they bring is both recognized and
respected and imagine a place where the
lessons we learn about diversity at work
actually transform the things we do
think and say outside of work that is
what happens if we
all work together to fix what's broken
that is what happens if we stop praying
for change to happen and actually start
moving our feet to making it that is the
power of single mindedness thank you
[Applause]